[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on s'en va là c'est bien bien
franchement franchement c'est hyper beau
mais ça vous irait très bien vous aussi
non t'emmerde pas non mais vraiment
emmerde pas si ça va toujours et ça
marche super bien tout va bien tout va
bien je réclame un verre qui roule ces
commandes ont maintenant ça commence à
dater et conscience et je sais pas je
compte 6 à 6 mois d'avancé sur le banc
ou quoi non mais qui cite arrive tôt non
mais je me souviens c'est quand je suis
arrivé à peu près donc
raymond tu regardes béatrice 1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait en vitrine
non mais je te le dit arrête parce que
tu regardes bien triste là sans déconner
en direct et devant les des coûts de
noël
je n'ai jamais vu comme ça j'en oublie
je n'oublie le croire n'oublie jamais
les genres la triste pour toi c'est le
fantasme absolu lancé s'élancera les
allergies la vérité il est attristé sera
pas très facile et mâcon secteur ont
versé fait beaucoup de confidences mais
après c'est très joli et tu le sais
béatrice malades avérés l'isis que la
piscine un moment après pas
qu'est ce que tu m'as dit de la piscine
art moma fantasmes sequana fantasmer je
me dis que voilà béatrice faut pas trop
qu'elle tourne autour de moi faux faux
faux l'éloigner
sur toi je crois qu'il tente pas du tout
liés
au papier de contact ne s'appelle pas
content content lundi ou mardi sa
radio mardi vraiment on s'appelle
j'étais numéro un ça va ça ne voulait
pas si je rechute comme j'ai fait là
n'hésitez pas à me le dire
béatrice est ce que raymond hahn
répète-t-on style ou la leur allez merci
ouais
[Applaudissements]
on est dans la fiction tu mets plus
marie voyer tu n'es plus américaine
vient du limousin et tu n'es pas varié
tu es célibataire et dit la vérité
raymond tu le faisais en amis ou en
avant
assez dur en amie madame savoir si c'est
possible je peux pas couché c'est bon
non plus
[Rires]
on n'a pas fini mais on va apprendre à
connaître les jo
gilles avec gilles oui tu as envie de le
connaître un mur d'argile mais en a mis
d'accord guillaume plus jeune guillaume
ça aurait été peut-être mes amis moi mon
plus jeune ce
week-end ce week-end passé les
volets comme un peuple que matthieu
delormeau le guen dickens pas
week-end williams r je crois qu'on a eu
le
dessus
ninon
attention parce que non jdo
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dino
oui oui oui oui oui pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas à toi oui c'est moi c'est
oui benjamin wittes onglet
v2 est l'ami à miami
sauvez
moi h page et coupleux pas couple mais
saches albaz ça pourrait être mon fils
tu ne regardes un super gars genre thème
cap d'un super
mais c'est vrai vous pouvez à brigitte
moi que ça alors alors
on fait du scooter derrière elle et
c'est un faux dit
non mais bon va très bien bombe alors
beaucoup de parents le sait maintenant
voilà bon bah c'est bon on a vu ce
qu'ils ne sont pas malheureusement
sélectionné
donné c'est la liste du sélectionneur
non mais c'est vrai il ya didier
deschamps lcd d'échec
[Applaudissements]
incroyable
lundi que la rédac je rappelle qu'il va
nous dire tout ce qui se passe bien sûr
aof dans l'émission oui et je voudrais
dire aux trois qui n'ont pas été
signalés les invendus vous vous
inquiétez pas ne pas plaire à tout le
monde je suis sûr qu'il ya d'autres gens
ici à qui vous plaidez se sait qu
isabelle voilà et kevin non mais c'est
vrai guillaume à l'équipe ben vous dit
où il est et ce qu'il faut si benjamin
donc voilà il n'y a pas non plus péril
en la demeure voilà un nom est vraiment
vraiment
vraiment pas bien demain tu prends pas
le camion je ne te laisserai pas prendre
le camion dans cet état
d'esprit j'arrive en pleine forme
béatrice si tu devais en choisir qu'un
ah là ce serait qui s'ils jouaient pas
mariés mais voilà oui un
futur réseau
d'antennes on n'est pas là pour rigoler
la vérité franchement c'est alors centre
mathieu nino et n'a rien guillaume elle
aime les blondes au maintien commandes
cérébrales n'y a pas beaucoup de moi
s'ils avouent manière bien mais c'est
papa
inité je suis bilingue
avec un avantage normal et moi je
me demandais je vous le demande ou la
gêne et la
voyez pas que vous lâcher des
noms mais bien peser une pression
avec ça
[Applaudissements]
tu te fais du mal bonsoir l'once pas et
fait un truc on fait du mal quand
messieurs ont déjà posé une question
c'est injuste poker oui une fois comme
ça si je n'étais pas mariée les jeunes
et les lib dems a dit mathieu plutôt oui
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas tu ne prends pas trop de
risques
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
voilà que tu prennes
way to go sony vraiment une américaine
un émissaire elle retombe toujours sur
saulx sur son big mac
peut-être qu'il aurait
ouais bah tant pis si moment j'ai pas
fait marcher la manuelle
me tenir là à mon avis il y compris
d'aller à côté 1
mais là c'est comme un pont loby il ya
des gars comme ça
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai voilà béatrice à
compte pas en mer de pas trop inquiète
pas voilà on est là devant même pas dans
le concours lui dès lors quoi il n est
pas familier
physique foot c'était juste mais c'est
pas non mais les mecs le physique c'est
un toupet l'animal a sonné la mets la
dans les pontois
alors si je vais vous dire la vérité je
voulais être boudés embarrassé
c'est pas vous que c'est embarrassant
pour quel motif j'en sais rien mais moi
j'aimerais bien qu'elle réponde non mais
l'attaqué va dire non avec ses
pouvoirs je ne sais pas
alors qu'on compte comment elle ya vu un
peu réduit en asie où il a chanté vexé à
votre place merci à l'aimer attrition
sais qu'elle m'aime beaucoup elle tue
pas la question c'est de l'amitié
ballack
était répondait librement
sans pression
[Applaudissements]
si j'ai dit ami je ne veux pas vexer
mamba non
tu ne bat pas du tout tu réfléchis trop
à la mairie tél ces bateaux-là théo théo
pmu lui répond pierre choquet
ça veut dire non tout cas pas dire oui
ça veut dire qu'est ce que tu fais ce
soir
on va pas se raconter d'histoires les
gars tu sais que tu fais après
l'émission voilà on va pas non plus
chercher midi à quatorze heures
qu'est-ce qui fait l'ami
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tapisserie
générale outre si c'est un écran à
l'évasion n'est pas ce tissu bon si la
chaux béatrice a
arrêté avec moi vous êtes en campagne
présidentielle la wii qu'elle est comme
moi vous êtes un homme politique
répondez répondait je vais te dire
c'est vrai elle va partir de
l'arrivée juste là donc on
commence et cyril si tu abuses gueule ce
que vous avez dit que je regarde ce qui
se passe pendant les pubs pendant l'ère
cependant émaillé tout mais j'écoute
aussi ce qui se dit en loge il ya un
instant un certain cyril h
il est à côté de moi
a prononcé cette phrase juste peut tout
balancer on est d'accord ce qui bat
santé tu te trouves a lancé après
[Rires]
joseph burr je ne suis pas du tout
content ça compte je ne suis pas contre
c'est vrai sont simples on
s'y est là un instant comment vous
sentez en soit on sortait très bien dans
un boom ou deux beaux gosses sont pas
franchement avocat l'instant incertain
série l'âge passant loges et 10 les
chroniqueurs se rendent pas compte
qu'ils ont un caviar en ce moment ils
ont un beau gosse qui se baladent dans
les loges et ils seront pas compte de ce
qu'ils ont de l'homme que je suis ici et
ça je trouve les gens voient que c'est
pas mal ce ne sont pas mes mots tu vois
si assez exactement ce que j'ai a
prononcé au guillaume six top 6 et momo
être super vous avez une belle peau vous
avez du talent vous avez un bon petit
boule bien ferme
aussi vous devrez choisir quelqu'un ici
pour une nuit ce serait qui ah bah vous
[Rires]
et vous
alors raymond puisqu'il demande je suis
en sécurité la taurine en sécurité créé
mon mari va lancer une nouvelle séquence
s'ouvre une
nouvelle séquence ça s'appelle le stop
ou encore en gros je veux un petit
extrait qui sont passés en off et c'est
vous qui décidez si vous avez vos
comptes à régler c'est maintenant que ça
se passe à la fin de l'extrait vous me
dites stop et là vous réglez vos comptes
a pas mal à vous aimez bien ça cet
atterrissage comment c'est moi qui les
sit in et les cdi des équipes ont
travaillé h2o un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
match encore
[Musique]
on commence un stop ou encore avec
matthieu delormeau qui ce n'est pas un
secret est payé à rien [ __ ] vous
prétendez vie sexuelle du couple
présidentiel avec des deux hommes qui me
choque un article qui
vous dormez vous êtes choqués mais je
suis très choqué mais je suis choquée
comme j'étais choqué ya pas très
longtemps de voir qu'un chanteur a
insulté le président de la république
est encore série la
série lh je crois qu'on n'est pas trop
qu'on vous contredisent sur ces mecs
pourquoi on n'a pas fait rentrer des
chroniqueurs à qui j'ai demandé qu
elle n'oublie jamais n'oublie jamais on
va plus que même quand j'ai tort j'ai
raison ou
encore quoi encore on passe au k2
benhaim quand vous avez une amie comme
valérie cyril part dans l'ennemi j'adore
vallier regarder les matchs je leur fais
un bisou elle va vous faire un petit
bisou
elle tremble
c'est un renard
[Rires]
aïe aïe aïe aïe cette journée vous avez
quelques secondes quelques minutes pour
préparer votre défense valérie benaïm je
vous le dis la sanction est immédiate
puisque ces duos neil stein directeur
général d'aj dos qui me gêne de la firme
et dans mon oreille the vous rires je ne
rigole pas
sachez qu'il ya un règlement intérieur
au sein d'âge 2 au sein de l'émission
pour toute insulte vulgarité colis b1
envers
la personne susdite dieu
c'est-à-dire ma personne
il n'y aura à chaque fois une baisse du
salaire de 30% normal ça donne valérie
benaïm en 3d c'est choisir si le mois de
septembre malheureusement le moment
serait à moins 30 pour
la boulaye suis gentil
et après bien entendu sa baisse de 10 %
à 10 % plus ça va jusqu'à arriver à 0%
et bien sûr et au bout d'un certain
moment vous nous devez dollar
photo nord éclair valérie bénaïm s'avère
qu'on a quand même on a quand même on en
a encore sous le pied c'est à dire mais
on peut quand même continuer
alors bien sûr après et un eagle il
vient de dire oui ça passe direct après
60 % va pas rester grand chose ouais non
métrage ici mais je dois me dédire ou
confirmés qu'est-ce que je ne vois pas
ce
qu'on voit pas ce que vous dites on
comprend pas benhaim on comprend par là
que répéter ce qu'elle a dit oui c'est
ce qui se passe parce que non mais
est-ce que vous me demandez de revenir
sur ma parole ou deux mètres de l'en but
alors je vous dis ici je ne demande rien
accord non ça tombe bien ça n'est pas
que c'est en fait comme bon vous semble
et bellugou rigole esclave je savais que
je vous montrerai où il va et c'est là
c'est l'horreur article 3 alinéa d'eau
gilles par contre +10
c'est très grave ce mollusque invention
bossu ça augmente la
dépense et foi dans la façon dont est
fait
[Rires]
toujours avec amour mais bon c'est bon
calme-toi quand même tu peux pas tout %
totti allez vas-y c'est très grave ce
qu'elle a fait est très grave très grave
donc on rappelle le magnéto c'est un
stop ou encore cyril peut régler ses
comptes à tout moment avec les
chroniqueurs en disant stop il a fait
avec valérie bénaïm qui a donc une perte
de salaire de 30%
six années 60 si ce n'est qu'elle devra
doser à cyril puisqu'il en manque
continue le body feux stop ou encore
avec matthieu delormeau attias est ce
que vous aviez des doutes cyril sur le
fait que ce soit un énorme lâche quoi
qu' il est question d'un sms c'est parce
que non je voudrais bien sûr un malheur
est ce qu il se passe des choses avec
pareil on aura bertrand d'écrire ça qui
est à 8 mois là il va bien il ya des
choses à nous dire voilà donc je vous
dis donc voilà je pilote l'émission en
direct vous le savez c'est vrai il ya
des choses qui se passent en direct donc
bertron va arriver dans quelques
instants je vous dis voilà il se passe
des choses je vous demandais cyril si
vous pensiez que matthieu delormeau
était un énorme lâchez vous aviez des
doutes alors matthieu delormeau oui je
crois qu'il fait un très très beau début
de saison car si l'accord c'est un gars
formidable oui et je la regarde pas le
mot j'espère j'aimerais bien pouvoir le
confirmer après ce match
si c'est pas un montage
en fin d'audience écoute moi je veux
dire quoi bon dos et inquiète pas timide
et laisse moi faire jeter l'île comme tu
kartonn ya toujours des gens qui savent
pas qu'ils s'en mêle
sans trop de succès voiture loi n'a
pas porté plainte à être
entendu ça fait
moderne au comptoir
pour moi tu as raison c'est un sujet
qu'il faut faire
il est fort
alors mathieu et je le dis et je ne
rigole pas à m'entendre sera destitué de
fmp
people6 dès la fin quoi oui mais non en
décembre mais non on sera déçu et
terminale sera benjamin castaldi mais
non mais non
[Applaudissements]
chaque spectateur profitez bien de cette
émission quand mais je ne rigole pas et
benjamin castaldi prendra la relève des
gens merci
cyril me punir mois mais le public
à 400000 personnes on va papa
djama fera beaucoup plus moche et bercy
après le magnéto qui a ressuscité
l'argent commenté mais si tu as besoin
d'argent dénommé mandat merci à partir
de 2023 tube a rebondi à ses pairs sama
et laisserait pas en voilà tu as une
très bonne tout réservé à venir et on
dirait jacques chirac comme s'ils
disaient les ondes
aller là mais tu l'auras après le
magnéto qui va suivre cyril matthieu
delormeau c'est pas en janvier qui va
quitter tpm paypal c'est dès ce samedi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que est ce que tu me qu'on ne
passe pas non parce que ce sont des
montages
ces kits envoyait le secure encore hier
il ya parmi nous après émission à jamais
la case du samedi à 19h merci des
sous-hommes 2029 oui le samedi
parce que depuis qu'il a eue le pmp
pipoles les audiences de ouf lui remonté
à la tête regardez que tu parles mais il
a pris entre tp people que vous l'avez
gracieusement mis sur un plateau une
émission plus les audiences de ouf plus
les rayons du magasin
incroyable ça veut dire quoi que veut
dire qu'il a pris goût là mais c'est à
dire que c'est pas un boulard qui l'a
pris c'est une montgolfière de regarder
s'il était créé
[ __ ] c'est qu'est ce que c'est long
[Musique]
ça commence à 19h des salaires et ça
tout ça
parce qu'hier
15h45 gmt
c'est la mine c'est leur vie bâtard
ce côté that happened à lhassa ça bouge
plus mais les gars voilà le même et nous
le salaire est envoyée
c'est pas une et pas des choses
brillantes aujourd'hui mettant quoi mais
c'est vrai
mais j'avoue que ce serait si seulement
je n'avais plus de 15 et plus rien on se
terminer à l'émission
capucine est encore plus belle
maintenant enceinte bah non c'est moi
[Musique]
ces projets
ça va que plus c'est gros
[Musique]
et ma bouteille d'eau fraîche
s'il te plaît oui parce que c'est pas
moi ma température que j'aime ça mais
pas dans deux heures à sion c'est bien
la peine
me dit pour être comme ça
[Applaudissements]
de plus beau qu'une femme enceinte
je pense que si quelqu'un qui m'a donné
la veille l'horreur mais ça donne moi la
phrase c'est qu'est-ce qu'on réfléchisse
à faire nos émissions on a vu ce que ça
donne incantations tout seul si déchirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand ils sont tous seuls 100 m pap et
un
évidement de repartir c'est leur dis que
tu penses de une catastrophe mais non
seulement tu es fou des lâches et
hypocrites a considéré était support de
ce sont ses prestations quand il est
seul il est nul
tu l'as vu l'émission cabinet j'ai
essayé samedi je les dires cyril j'ai
tenu douze minutes et une lada est
maussade a compris peut-être non mais
c'est vrai que ça me s amnistie
catastrophe un oui à bateau faisait pas
vous y mettez vous dans sport mon âge il
est vrai je ne vais pas dû y est pas bon
venir a vu beaucoup de gens vous l'avez
pas vu sinon tu as vu de producteurs
mais alors mais attends mais chez d&g
les gens qui produisent pas à temps mais
c'est moi qui ai donné tout le de la
trame après je n'ai pas envie de voir le
le massacre
sur série la merci gilles tient n'essaye
pas de défausser sur cyril temin eu des
fausses par régine vous êtes quoi en est
si taper mois dessus non mais moi je
suis toujours comme ça me fait ça me
fait non c'est même pas de la com ça
donne encore plus envie de cartonner de
réussir de plaire au public qui le sort
j'ai demandé
je demandais bien entendu à toutes les
femmes enceintes d'autres bals regarde
tous allez vas-y elle avant de repartir
tout ce qui se passe on and off pendant
les magnétos c'est la gazette des offres
sais pas ce qu'il dit
c'est lequel est le plus gros problème
sur ce plateau à part gilles verdez le
réseau bien sûr pour assiatou pas
et toujours capter voyez ça tout de
suite dealer consorts dealers qui casse
les murs
merci chéri qui suit vous demander tout
ce que fait cyril pendant les pubs bars
garder bien avait les yeux tu allais
dire que les vieux que des voeux qu au
niveau du bar les dieux que les vieux
que des vieux tu deviens que les vieux
qu on y va on y va on y va on y va on y
va en avoir ni vent ni vent je vous ai
vue aucune qui au niveau du mode
histoire et c'est parti on y va on y va
di ballo dieu qu on y va on y va on va
regarder les beaux et des plus à les
brûler vos idées on sait nos études et
qdq n'est qu'une et que des cubis mal
vécu dix balles
et vous pensez peut-être aussi que celle
il était hyper concentré pendant ses
interviews bas à padoue la france bref
on s'est quand même le premier
producteur mondial d'électricité
mondiale au delà du niveau de folie je
crois que les gens je vais quand même
deux ris je vais un peu cassée l'an dans
ce cas c'est long
vous pensez peut-être également que
celle il apprécié tous ses chroniqueurs
hors antenne papa doc non plus
[Musique]
paris ses chats la bourgogne on est
monté à kaunas j'temmerde savoir
traitons pas toi qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
alors ses parents
alors oui ça trou du cul mais non c'est
pas
et si les mollets les vrais problèmes de
réseau sur ce plateau la preuve avec
jean michel maire d'istres avord dans la
rue
l'écologie
c'est moi c'est une pression à chaque
fois
sympathique et on finit avec vous s'il
est cette année en deux mots
sympathiques et bienveillance
françois hollande agi par peur
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien ce que fait unique
c'est bien ça tu vas y aller
oui merci d'alema
[Applaudissements]